make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and uh
i want to cover
the planet of the symbiotes at least the
second issue the first part of the
second issue
is part of the part of king and black
okay here's something to specify with
regards to planet of the symbiotes this
is one of marvel's attempts at an old
throwback comic and it's actually not
bad
it's really good it's really really
really really good um the one with
american kaiju this is basically
you know marvel's version of godzilla uh
it's cool it's interesting
but the planet of the symbiotes really
is just an anthology series right it's
just a book that collects a series of
smaller stories
which i think is a genius idea mostly
because of the fact that it gives us the
ability to see characters that we don't
normally get to see or that we haven't
seen in a long time
and then like an attempt to see whether
or not you know we're interested in
seeing anything more from them
the first issue i would say the big
standout star the first issue is
probably scream i've never cared about
scream so i didn't really much care
about the fact that she was in that book
i was like
moving on and that was basically it but
american kaiju here's the thing todd
ziller american kaiju was a great
concept that was terribly executed right
so the idea here with american kaiju to
kind of
backstep this a little bit in fact there
really isn't a whole lot that goes on in
this comic so we can just kind of
peruse through the comic as we're
producing this story as i'm kind of
giving you guys some backstory here uh
so the idea behind this is that for
those of you guys who remember when
marvel launched the original not really
the original the 2015 secret wars event
in the aftermath of that we got all new
all different marvel which was not all
new and it was not all different it was
basically the same thing with a few
couple change-ups right so marvel
basically turned a branding initiative
into a buzzfeed article just complete in
total clickbait and so the result of
this is that a lot of us were pissed but
then other people were mad because they
didn't like the way that marvel had a
lot of their stories
but at the outset of that we basically
got all new all different avengers
and what you had here was that instead
of you of you having advanced idea
mechanics you had avengers idea
mechanics and that was designed to build
on the idea that robert decosta who was
previously an x-men
had basically bought advanced idea
mechanics and taken it over towards the
end
of uh jonathan hickman's avengers and
new avengers and it was really hickman
just kind of wrapping up all these loose
threads and kind of bringing all the
various groups that existed out there
superheroes especially
in an attempt to like find a way to stop
the incursions and it didn't work
just talking about that makes you want
to go back and cover avengers and new
avengers again but we just finished
remastering it and we're never going to
remaster it again so now i just have to
go back and read it again right i can i
can
i cannot remaster a remaster that's just
one step too far right it's just
you're just surfing for views that's
that's all that is you're here to
surfing for youtube money
but uh nonetheless the idea was that
with with this particular team
functioning the way that it was there
was yet another attempt at marvel to
bring back the super soldier program now
marvel does that occasionally the you
know you go back to the old like abraham
erskine captain america comics and you
have the idea that like
you know steve rogers was injected with
the super soldier serum and then abraham
erskine died with the formula before it
could be passed on to anybody else and
so
the the formula itself was essentially
lost after that you just had like a
whole host of attempts to duplicate the
super soldier serum or make something
similar to it so like that's where the
century robert reynolds comes from
that's how you got
all the weapons plus weapon programs
right so like weapons
two three four five six all the way up
to like weapon x or weapon ten with
wolverine and even the ones beyond that
phantom x uh the stepper kakoos who are
just clones of emma frost
different things like that the problem
that the all-new avengers ran into
was that with all the knowledge of
abraham erskine gone and even the people
who came after abraham erskine so like
carol hines and professor thornton and
abraham cornelius who were the three
individuals that were the most
responsible for turning wolverine from
logan into wolverine and the weapon x
project and even as part of weapons plus
canada's department k all that kind of
stuff because all that information was
gone
uh what the all-new avengers basically
had to do was kind of frankenstein
together
a super soldier serum of sorts and so
what they ended up doing was combining
the knowledge they did have of the super
soldier serum what limited knowledge
they did have
alongside the mutant growth hormone pym
particles and the conor's formula which
turned
connors into the lizard and then
basically injecting this this you know
crazy cocktail into todd zigler which
turned him into this godzilla-esque
character now one of the reasons why you
never really saw anything come after
that or
really come out of his character is you
did have the storyline in issue number
nine which ran into issues 10
and i think even as far back as issue
number seven is that he did go on a
mission to like rescue rick jones right
the friends of the incredible hulk and
so on and so forth but for the most part
there was a lot of
disdain towards all new all different
marvel from a lot of older fans who felt
betrayed and a lot of newer fans who had
no idea what the heck was going on
because it just felt so
so far removed from what they expected
to see in marvel comics especially those
coming from the movies who expected like
the movie adaptation in comics and then
taking their lead from a lot of fans who
didn't really like all new all different
marvel it turned people off to the
concept
and so it's kind of like okay this thing
exists moving on you know and just sort
of sort of running on
to the next thing now i personally
didn't have a whole lot of grudge with
all new all different marvel i really
didn't have a lot of beef with it uh it
was just kind of a thing that was there
you know and so i enjoyed it you know
it was fun it had great moments and had
bad moments just like every single comic
book era in the history of comic books
in general
but uh but that was kind of the story of
todd ziller right now
in terms of this right like what's going
on here and why he's in this place
it's pretty simple and pretty
straightforward right he was basically
just released by the federal government
because he's one of the few beings that
looks like he can stand against the
power of the
of the dragons of knoll now a lot of
this comes down to like the nature of
the powers he possesses right so because
he's essentially kind of a frankenstein
of these different elements of
of you know marvel's science division
more or less
uh he has kind of like the the healing
ability of the lizard he's got the
ability or at least
he he does grow in size like we see with
hangry with with pym particles when
uh you know hank pym or scott lang or
any one of those guys ends up becoming
like
giant man more or less uh but he's also
got you know powers that are similar but
not exact
to abomination and the hulk right so he
has like the strength level of the hulk
along with like the aggression and rage
of abomination but it's not limitless
strength right it's not like you know
the the anger he gets the stronger he
gets it doesn't necessarily
include that thing just just because of
the fact that he was exposed to gamma
radiation treatments right so he doesn't
really have the same
exact principles of the incredible hulk
but just by sheer size and strength
alone he's more than enough to go
against these dragons now at the end of
the day it doesn't really make a whole
lot of difference here because we know
that like the guy who's leading all this
null
is powerful enough to conscript you know
celestials into his into his bidding
right so anybody who can conscript
celestials these cosmic gods that create
life are certainly going to be far more
powerful than a hybrid of of
you know giant man and the incredible
hulk and abomination
and somebody who's on mutant growth
hormone to like amplify their powers
even further right so you know
the guy's strong he's wildly capable but
he's basically just marvel's version of
godzilla now i doubt you're gonna see
anything more from him out of this right
you may see a little bit more over the
course of king and black but this little
book here is not written by donny cates
so it's not as though donnie kate sees
uh you know sees american kaiju todd
ziller as somebody a can
that can actually like show up
consistently over the course of the
venom run and even if he did
uh the venom runs coming to an end right
we know it's coming to a close with like
maybe a story arc after the end of king
and black and that's basically
that's it for donnie kate's run what he
works on next i don't know i don't care
i'll read it regardless
but uh but yeah this is basically the
the idea behind
todd ziller i mean he he it's like super
hyper patriotic which you guys can tell
just by looking at what's going on here
he's like a hyper patriot right so he's
like america never makes any mistakes or
anything like that you know america's
always the only way to go he's very
similar to frank simpson to nuke
in that way uh but again you know
there's not a whole lot going
with this story it's literally just like
it's like a seven issue story where it's
like we have a we have marvel's version
of godzilla who's just in new york
tearing some stuff up and he feels a
little bit bad that he's destroying
things that belong to people
but it's all in greater service there's
all in service of a greater whole
because he's just destroying the
symbiote dragons of
of uh of knoll and that's cool i will
say this his design is amazing and one
of the big shames is you never really
see anything come out of it it'd be
different if this was back in like the
1970s
when like fenfang foom was like a great
big huge deal then sure if you
had been created back then you'd see a
lot of prominence with this character
but for the most part you don't really
see anything going on with it right he's
just kind of here and he's doing some
things and that's basically it and then
the story basically just kind of ends
right it's like ending dot dot dot and
that's basically it
we might see a follow-up i'm not really
sure but i doubt it right because he
ends up just kind of reverting back into
his human form
and then that's effectively it but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end uh if you guys are new
here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob for if you guys
want me to cover the original story
where we first saw american kaiju
i can do it it's not going to kill me or
anything it's a one-off story right so i
mean we can do that on like a random
saturday or like a sunday or something
like that
if you guys want that let me know i mean
i don't have any problem doing it i
think it'd be kind of cool right so just
leave some comments down below and uh i
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
you